[Musique]
en prononçant cette petite phrase la
journaliste audrey pulvar ne s'attendait
peut-être pas à soulever un tsunami de
réactions
et pourtant le sujet est sensible
interrogé par apolline de manière sur la
polémique autour de l'unef ce syndicat
étudiant dont la présidente explique et
organiser des réunions dans lesquelles
les blancs n'étaient pas admis audrey
pulvar a expliqué au sujet des ateliers
de parole autour des victimes du racisme
que les blancs pouvaient y être admis
mais il n'est pas question de l'heure où
la jeter dehors
en revanche on punit demandé de se taire
pour elle il s'agit de témoigner du
racisme les blancs n'ont pas à
intervenir
une position qui a grandement fait
réagir dans les médias le vrai problème
c'est la lutte contre le racisme
mais la solution ça ne peut pas passer
par de l'exclusion de son côté l'homme
politique renaud muselier a qualifié
cette intervention de racisme anti blanc
cette fois d'audrey pulvar les racistes
en république n'ont aucune bonne raison
au monde ne donne le droit de faire
taire une personne pour sa couleur de
peau alors les blancs sont priés de se
taire la phrase d'audrey pulvar est elle
raciste
merci à rokhaya diallo d'être avec nous
bien sûr rocha et des lots convention
dans l'émission essayiste et militante
s'avachir et d'amour merci à toi tu es
toujours magnifique cyril bennasar merci
d'être là essayiste auteur de l'art lac
antiraciste expliqué à ma soeur réponse
à rokhaya diallo
oui c'est la première fois que vous êtes
sur un plateau ensemble ces voix là bas
vous voyez comme quoi tout arrive merci
cyril da ns la merci en tout cas banon
match énorme alors voilà on va écouter
tous les avis ici dans cette émission et
chez lisabeth lévy venir elle sera la
bienvenue également cotées se lève tôt
déjà le fait déjà un peu trop d'antenne
c'est le sien qu'est-ce qui se passe
sony qui dit que c'est raciste géraldine
maillet oui parce qu'effectivement enfin
en tout cas je sais pas si c'est raciste
mais c'est très maladroit parce
qu'effectivement il ya une
discrimination à l'embauché
évidemment il ya des délits de faciès
évidemment il ya là il ya des brebis
galeuses dans la police qui sont
racistes
mais malgré tout il ya une sorte d'
essentialisation où on a l'impression
que finalement la population et la
population française est raciste et moi
je pense que ces groupes de paroles sont
complètement contre-productif
elle ne crée pas du lien elle ne crée
pas du dialogue on est les uns contre
les autres
alors donc les noirs vont se plaindre du
racisme des blancs les femmes vont se
plaindre du sexisme des hommes quand on
est métisse qu'est ce qu'on fait on a un
papa noir une maman de lenche on est
dans quel dilemme vers qu'en fait on est
comme si on reproduisait une ségrégation
alors qu'on n'a pas de ségrégation en
france
je trouve que c'est très dangereux et
dans la pratique pardon dans l'absence
et la théorie à la limite mais dans la
pratique par exemple le document
de porto là non on dit bon alors
mesdames vous avez été victime de
sexisme on veut absolument pas qui est
des hommes dans nos groupes de parole ok
bon pourquoi pas mais en fait on va pas
avancer comme ça c'est à dire que les
femmes vous restez entre elles elles
vont il a été violent il a été sali il a
été comme art il a été inondé il a été
un vif et donc concrètement non il faut
que les hommes soient là et se confronte
à cette réalité est qu'on puisse avancer
tous ensemble et pas qu'on s'exprime
isabelle bluetooth et une souris que je
trouve que c'est très raciste on
n'arrête pas de nous dire qu'il faut
apprendre à vivre ensemble et qu'il faut
vraiment arrondir les angles etc etc et
là brusquement en quinze jours on ne
remet face à face un clivage blanc noir
je trouve que c'est désastreux pour la
notion de vivre ensemble est extrêmement
dangereux à l'heure actuelle alors vous
recueillez vous trouvez que cette phrase
ne vous choque pas la phrase telle
qu'elle a été formulée le comte manquer
les surprises désagréables rouler qu'on
la revoie eux je pense que ce n'est pas
nécessaire et que audrey bouchard a déjà
été très va la revoir quand même cet
atelier une femme blanche un homme blanc
et ses bas j'aurais tendance à 2,10 à la
dire qu' il n'est pas question de le ou
la jeter dehors
en revanche on peut lui demander de se
taire ont pu donner on peut lui demander
d'être spectatrice spectateurs
silencieux peut lui demander de se taire
oui je pense que oui parce que pour le
coup moi je ne dis pas qu'il faille
qu'il soit il ou elle interdit d'entrée
mais au moins qui tient à l'aise et
qu'il réagit parmi les personnes qui
étaient ils ou elles se taisent et
laisse parler les personnes les plus
concernées
oui c'est compliqué comme ça parce qu'en
fait la question c'est la question des
groupes de parole les profits des
groupes de parole c'est un principe très
anciens par exemple quand des femmes se
réunissent pour parler de violences
sexuelles ou de violence sexiste
il est plus facile pour elle de
s'exprimer entre elles que en présence
d'un homme ou de plusieurs hommes
et ça ce sont les espaces qui sont
temporaires qui dure un temps ses passes
sont pas des espaces définitive et dans
l'intervention d'audrey pulvar ce
qu'elle disait que je trouve très
intéressant ce que disait par exemple si
des personnes sont elles les bété cuit
ya et s'organise donc des personnes
homosexuelles lesbiennes gays trans etc
ou bi se réunisse entre elle
il ne viendra pas à l'esprit de deux
d'imposer sa présence c'est pas eu
millions en fait c'est pas infamant de
reconnaître que parfois des gens ont
besoin temporairement
se réunir pour parler de leurs
conditions parce que c'est plus facile
et ça libère la parole alors tout le
monde a réagi bien sûr rachida dati
défoncé valérie pécresse geoffroy didier
marlène schiappa l'ice cunti vous saviez
bertron
voila voila marine le pen bien sûr
gilbert collard et puis l'enfant et
benoît qu'ils ont
ils ont défendu série b nasa moi je
trouve que la phrase est raciste enfin
quelques onces cautionne une pratique un
système raciste
je veux bien entend les arguments de
rokhaya diallo sur les groupes de parole
je veux bien qu'on adapte à des femmes
battues qui voudraient parler entre
elles de leurs problèmes sans être
dérangé par des hommes
mais les noirs ne sont pas les femmes
battues des blancs en france c'est pas
seulement forcément uniquement des
personnes noires ça peut être des
personnes de personnes rayo j'imagine
mais enfin ce sont les blancs qui sont
exclues parce que on entre dans un
système dans lequel on divise la
population en deux catégories les
dominants et les dominés et forcément
les dominants dans votre approche sont
toujours les blancs les deux minutes
mais nous observons des femmes par
exemple qui peuvent être victimes de
sexisme l'homophobie peuvent peut-être
de petites couleurs simplement s'agit
d'un espace temporaire il s'agit
simplement pendant un temps comme comme
le principe des alcooliques anonymes
c'est à dire que pendant un temps on
parle de notre souffrance on parle de
notre douleur on essaie de trouver des
solutions on va réunir et après apporter
à l'ensemble des sociétés c'est à dire
que c'est pas une ségrégation définitifs
sont des gens qui temporairement se
disent qu'on va avoir un espace où on
peut respirer être tout simplement oui
montre nous mêmes mais ce n'est pas
définitif
nicolas pernikoff apprendre au corps
syria's une question d'accord qu elle
vous rend pas service quand même parce
que de la manière mais à nous et je me
sens pas je vous embrasse les jeux sont
pas hyper à l'aise avec la formulation
nous pose problème mais le principe me
dérange pas qu'on aurait sciemment okaya
ok mais là on est content de se calmer
quand même on va pas les jeter dehors on
va pas leur interdire c'est à dire
donner c'est un terrible aussi vous je
comprends je comprendrais formulation
moi je serai fort moi j'ai toujours
défendues principe de ces réunions c'est
à dire qu on dise on est dans un groupe
on décide par exemple il ya en france un
groupe qui s'appelle l'union des
étudiants juifs de france parce qu'à un
moment donné dans l'histoire les
étudiants juifs ont eu besoin de se
réunir pour parler de la problématique
ce qui n'empêche pas cette association
le giec de collaborer avec sos racisme
chercheur lutter contre toutes les
formes de racisme
donc il ya parfois des moments on a
besoin de sérogroupe et cette terre
qu'il est peut être maladroit elle a mal
formulée mais je pense que le panama
l'ipaf n invalide pas le principe je
pense que l'eau et des collants mais on
connaissait que c'est une forme de
racisme
non parce que il s'agirait de leurs
assises c'est priver quelqu'un de
quelque chose
imagine
les quelques uns de ces noms vous dit on
dit souvent que les mots ont un sens
imaginez la même phrase où on prononce
non mais alors les noirs sont priés de
se taire sarr est ok couturier dit c'est
du racisme président lasana mais je
comprends ce que vous dites mais dans la
syntaxe dans les mots et on dit que les
montrent un sens étendu les formant à
l'usso s'est passé on peut pas on peut
interdire aux cayes à la 10 matches peut
pas dire que le dos vincent c'est
raciste
ça sent la formulation est problématique
mais le principe n'est pas un principe
d'exclusion c'est à dire que dans une
société où les personnes des personnes
sont déjà discriminées
si elles se réunissent à paris l'a dit
leur discrimination ce n'est pas
l'exclusion des autres simplement la
réunion d'intérêt commun c'est à dire
que c'est comme si vous êtes un alcool
vous êtes alcoolique vous réunissez par
une mise l'alcoolique anonyme pour
parler de votre condition parce que
c'est pas facile d'en parler en dehors
de ce sac ça veut pas dire que vous
discriminer les personnes qui ne sont
pas alcooliques pourrais vous dire que
pendant un temps vous ayez trouvé des
solutions pour nous entraidons cependant
talent peut pas les centres locaux pour
moi de des noirs c'est ça pour une
baisse sensible s'il peut être sensible
mais ça veut dire que ça veut pas dire
que ces deux de tout temps dans tous les
espaces on les exclut ça veut dire que
temporairement
et ça veut dire que bien sûr que
benjamin vous ne pouvez pas comprendre
exactement ce que je ressens quand je
vis une discrimination évidemment est ce
que vous ne vivez pas c'est à dire que
non moi si je viens et je vous explique
des choses extrêmement personnelle par
rapport à la manière dont je dois
réfléchir
ah si je vais dans une émission et ce
qui est ma couleur de peau de fontanes
etc
je sais qu'une personne noire va le
comprendre automatiquement alors que oui
dont je fasse un chemin pour vous
l'exigez le chemin qu'ils ont chez moi
parce que je suis une charge
supplémentaire discussion à la et on n'a
pas justement on organise des réunions
pour ne pas avoir en plus à prendre la
charge de ce chemin pour vous expliquer
c'est le chemin là je peux l'expliquer
ce soir d'ailleurs je le fais ce soir
sans aucun problème mais peut être que
demain j'aurai envie d'en parler avec
des gens qui vont comprendre directement
disons que j'ai eu à y investir de
l'énergie non mais c'est marrant comme
avec une petite phrase ou des articles
circule sur twitter que les gens lisent
pas en entier on peut dire n'importe
quoi pour moi y'a rien de raciste là
dedans faut arrêter de voir du racisme
partout
nicolas tu parler de foot dehors les
gens et c'est pourquoi il a dit ça parce
qu'elle réagit a déjà la première
polémique de l'unef qui accusait qui
était accusé d'interdire les réunions au
blanc alors que ce n'était pas le cas à
eux mêmes n'ont jamais parlé
d'interdictions qu'est ce qu'elle fait
là de quoi elle parle crédit jusqu'en
fait qu'on tient là toi la confiance non
elle n'a pas pu
elle n'a jamais parlé d'interdictions ça
n'a jamais été dit dans la bouche de la
présidente de l'unef
elle dit juste et elles disent juste
qu'en fait quand il ya un groupe de
parole ce qui est pas l'intégralité des
réunions mais c'est un style de réunion
un groupe de parole ce sont des gens qui
sont concernés par une problématique qui
s'exprime sur cette problématique au
contraire audrey pulvar elle tempère ses
propos elle dit les gens qui ne sont pas
concernés peuvent venir mais ils ne
doivent pas parler parce qu'ils ne sont
pas concernés c'est normal on a le droit
de laisser une interdiction réservé aux
seins c'est forcément on joue sur les
mots mais votre exemple des femmes
battues il est très bon un homme avait
assez de l'union il n'a pas à s'exprimer
puisqu'il n'est pas concerné il n'a pas
témoigné
ils veulent ils en témoignent devant on
peut comprendre ça en france on peut pas
comprendre que cette limite passe par le
critère de la race mais monsieur sur le
chinois en france qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que moi branle jeudi dans cette
réunion je le fais venir
je suis pas d'accord je pense que même
en tant que blanc je peux tout à fait
comprendre toute forme de discrimination
même raciale me direz ça marche dans
tous les sens les hommes avec les femmes
je veux dire la littérature est pleine
flaubert écrit madame bovary
on peut pour moi pas lui dire qu'il
savait pas se mettre à la place d'une
femme oui mais les personnages de femmes
dans les films de woody allen se sont
absolument superbes faisait la création
pas le meilleur exemple pour aller au
cinéma dans les personnages de deux
femmes qu'il a mis en scène sinon ça at
il dit ça fout les monts raciste manuel
est en campagne donc pour les régionales
en île de france et que ça patine et que
c'est un grand coup de barre à gauche
mae sai et voilà d'ailleurs on voit bien
les réactions sont fortes à droite et à
gauche
globalement on la soutient donc voilà
elle essaye de relancer sa campagne
après sur le fond monsieur je suis pas
d'accord et lyon parce que écouter aller
dans une réunion et écoutez c'est pas
être exclue mais c'est salvateur
d'écouté parfois quand vous écoutez
l'autre expliqué pourquoi il est
discriminé en l'occurrence un noir qui
explique à d'autres noah entre pourquoi
ils sont discriminés pourquoi c'est
difficile pourquoi la vie quotidienne
est plus difficile oui quand on est noir
que quand on est blanc ça c'est vrai
vous ne le niez pas je ne nie pas mais
je relativise beaucoup de bruit mais
veut retrouver les bains ya beaucoup de
discrimination qui ne sont pas allés
dans un groupe de parole une réunion et
écoutez franchement ça peut faire du
bien et faire prendre conscience
n'exclut pas elle demande de l'écouté
moi je trouve que c'est sale va voir
et oui à 80% oui à 91 à 19% à la halle
sondages il est sans appel je pense que
la question c'est vraiment la question
de l'humilité monsieur bennassar pense
qu'il peut comprendre toutes les
défaillances de tout le monde moi les
l'humilité de comprendre que par exemple
si des personnes sont transgenres mois
l'interrogation quand je vais par
exemple je vais s'il doit me rendre aux
toilettes je sais très bien où je dois
aller si on est non binaire si on est
transgenre c'est une question qu'on se
pose qui ne vient pas à l'esprit et
c'est une expérience que je ne peux pas
avoir un tweet il ment parce qu'elle
jeunes à travers pas dans ma chair et
j'essaie l'humilité de reconnaître que
je ne suis pas omniscient tels que je ne
connais pas tous les sondages ça vous
dit ils sont durs mais moi j'ai
l'habitude de combattre sont dp des
positions qui sont minoritaires
je veux dire je comprends que les gens
n'aient pas pensé que cela parce qu'elle
n'a pas le temps de développer michel
dit audrey pulvar encore une fois que
elle n'aurait pas l'arrogance de
s'imposer dans une réunion de personnes
lgbt cuillère ça veut dire que c'est pas
une excuse elle reconnaît je connais je
connais bien la voilà avec qui j'ai
longuement travaillé ma vérité voilà sur
ces 8 c voilà c'est une jeune fille
voilà le sait un petit ami j'aime
beaucoup qui équipe qui est pas du tout
raciste 1 voilà je pense que comme vous
avez dit la formulation est maladroite
ouais enfin c'est dommage qu'on n'ait
pas le temps de développer sur le
principe et les bienfaits que peuvent
avoir ces réunions c'est à dire que les
gens ça leur fait du bien
m'ont donné il faut comprendre que pour
ios était apaisée il ya des gens qui ont
besoin de se retrouver la question de la
communauté qu'il s'agisse de la
communuaté femme idéale communal et ses
bars dont la maman c'est à dire qu'ils
se retrouveront s'apaiser pour mieux
servir l'ensemble de la société cas il
faut pas arrêter la pêche blanche ça
n'empêche pas ces temporaires c'est à
dire que c'est pas parce qu'on lui
souhaite une réunion de deux heures que
vous n'allez pas jamais parlé avec
d'autres personnes quand vous pensez
quoi de ce que dit moi je pense que ce
qui pose problème quand même dans ces
affaires de rassemblement entre racisées
entre famous et que c'est le cadre
public de la chose ça se passe dans le
cadre d'une université d'un syndicat si
c'était une réunion privée on s'oriente
en privé par affinités ses amis ont fait
un barbecue on a vite que des noirs
parce qu'on veut voir que des noirs et
aucun problème mais le fait que ce soit
affiché publiquement
que ce soit cautionné par quelqu'un qui
est une élue une journaliste reconnu ça
nous fait basculer dans un monde que je
ne je ne veux pas pour l'heure c'est pas
nouveau le mouvement de libération des
serfs des femmes a fondé son
émancipation sur ce principe là c'est
quelque chose de très
c'est des choses qui comprend 16 entre
hommes et femmes oui c'est ma vraie
blanc a décidé de ne pas voir là on s'en
fout la paix s'est décidé en fait c'est
la france c'est la tradition france et
l'universalisme forcément foutait
libéralisme mais ça ne peut pas être une
institution publique qui organise et qui
sépare les noirs des blancs pour mes
frais pour les femmes et pas pour les
autres groupes
parce que les femmes peuvent avoir des
problèmes encore jeu du bruit vous êtes
une femme commence à faire concernant
les machines etc des femmes battues ou
des femmes n'ont finalement d'avoir un
homme enfin si mais vous ne vivez pas
évidemment mais ça va m c'est dans ces
cas là dans le cadre d'une séparation
raciale je trouve ça un gène préparation
merci à vous c'est vraiment sur audrey
pulvar 80% des gens trouvent que sa
phrase était raciste merci rokhaya
diallo favori avec nous merci cyril
bennasar ici est auteurs de l'arnaqué
antiraciste expliqué à ma soeur réponse
à rokhaya diallo il a fait un peu moins
fraternel au niveau de l'échangé mais
l'idée est l'idée la wii merci en tout
cas